سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي عهد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
اصحاب الجلاله والسياده والسمو
السيدات والساده
من اين يبدا المرء حديثه والاخطار لم تعد
محدقه بل محققه
يبدا من الامل الدافع للانجاز والعمل
وعندما تتراكم العلل يمكن للطبيب ان
يعالجها فراده شرط ان يعالج المرض الاساسي
المسبب له
فاذا علينا ان نبحث عن العناوين الكبرى
التي تهدد مستقبلنا وتنتج ازماتنا
كي لا نغرق ونغرق الاجيال القادمه بمعالجه
النتائج لا الاسباب
والتهديدات فيها مخاطر وفيها فرص ونحن
اليوم امام فرصه تتبدل الوضع الدولي الذي
يتبدى بعالم متعدد الاخطاب كنتيجه لهيمنه
الغرب المجرد من المبادئ والاخلاق
والاصدقاء والشركاء
هي فرصه تاريخيه لاعاده ترتيب شؤوننا باقل
قدر من التدخل الاجنبي وهو ما يتطلب اعاده
موضوعنا في هذا العالم الذي يتكون اليوم
ان يكون جزءا فاعلا فيه مستثمرين في
الاجواء الايجابيه الناشئه عن المصالحات
التي سبقت القمه وصولا اليها اليوم
هي فرصه لترسيخ ثقافتنا في مواجهه الذوبان
القادم مع الليبراليه الحديثه التي تستهدف
الانتماءات الفطريه للانسان وتجرده من
اخلاقه وهويته
ولتعريفه هويتنا العربيه ببعدنا ببعدها
الحضاري وهي تتهم زورا بالعرقيه
والشوفينيه بهدف جعلها في حاله صراع مع
المكونات الطبيعيه القوميه والعرقيه
والدينيه فتموت وتموت معها مجتمعاتنا
بصراعها مع ذاتها لا مع غيرها
العناوين كثيره لا تتسع لها كلمات ولا
تكفيها قمم
لا تبدا عند جرائم الكيان الصهيوني
المنبوذ عربيا بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
المقاوم ولا تنتهي عند خطر الفكر العثماني
التوسعي المطعم بنكهه اخوانيه منحرفه ولا
تنفصل عن تحدي التنميه كاولويه قصوى
لمجتمعاتنا الناميه
هنا ياتي دور جامعه الدول العربيه
باعتبارها المنصه الطبيعيه لمناقشه
القضايا المختلفه
ومعالجتها شرطه تطوير منظومه عملها عبر
مراجعه الميثاق والنظام الداخلي وتطوير
الياتها كي تتماشى مع العصر
فالعمل العربي المشترك بحاجه لرؤى
واستراتيجيات واهدافها مشتركه نحولها
لاحقا الى خطط تنفيذيه بحاجه لسياسه موحده
ومبادئ ثابته واليات وضوابط واضحه عندها
سننتقل من رد الفعل الى السباق الاحداث
وستكون جامعه متنفسا في حاله الحصار لا
شريكا به ملجا من العدوان لا منصه له
اما عن القضايا التي تشغلنا يوميا من
ليبيا الى سوريا مرورا باليمن والسودان
وغيرها من القضايا الكثيره في مناطق
مختلفه فلا يمكننا معالجه الامراض عبر
معالجه الاعراض
فكل تلك القضايا هي نتائج لعناوين اكبر لم
تعالج سابقا اما الحديث في بعضها فهو
بحاجه لمعالجه التصدعات التي نشات على
الساحه العربيه خلال عقد مضى واستعاده
جامعه لدورها كمرممه لجروح لكعمق لها
والاهم هو ترك القضايا الداخليه لشعوبها
فهي قادره على تدبير شؤونها وما علينا الا
ان نمنع التدخلات الخارجيه في بلدانها
ونساعدها عند الطلب حصرا
اما سوريا فمضيها وحاضرها ومستقبلها هو
العروبه لكنها عروبه الانتماء لا عروبه
الاحضان فالاحضان عابره اما الانتماء
فدائم وربما ينتقل الانسان من حضن لاخر
لسبب ما لكنه لا يغير انتمائه اما من
يغيره فهو من دون انتماء من الاساس ومن
يقع في القلب لا يقبع في حضن وسوريا قلب
العروبه وفي قلبها
السيدات والساده
ونحن نعقد هذه القمه في عالم مضطرب فان
الامل يرتفع في ظل التقارب العربي العربي
والعربي الاقليمي والدولي والذي توج بهذه
القمه والتي اتمنى ان تشكل بدايه مرحله
جديده للعمل العربي للتضامن فيما بيننا
للسلام في منطقتنا للتنميه والازدهار بدلا
من الحرب والدمار والتزاما بالدقائق الخمس
المخصصه للكلمات اتوجه بالشكر العميق
لرؤساء الوفود الذين عبروا عن الموده
المتاصله تجاه سوريا وابادلهم بالمثل كما
اذكر خادم الحرمين الشريفين على الدور
الكبير الذي قام به وجهود المكثفه التي
بذلها لتعزيز المصالحه في منطقه
هذه القمه واتمنى له والاسم ولي العهد
وللشعب السعودي الشقيق دوام التقدم
والازدهار
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]